so aoc you know she
you know whatever we say about aoc
politically which you know we may or may
not agree with socialism you know how
she capitalizes of all the opportunities
she's been able to get her message out
there to hundreds of millions of people
at this point the entire country knows
who she is she's got god knows how many
followers on twitter 10 15 million
followers on twitter what do you think
she's doing that's resonating because
may 11th you just had a birthday happy
birthday to you two weeks
29 years old you your age starts with
the number two
we skip here tyler you're how old just
so we know 34 27 no 27 years old okay
and then
there's there's a spike there's no three
here then it's four and five in the room
so for the 20 year olds yourself what
what makes you think an aoc uh is
getting the kind of connection with the
younger audience where they're saying
she makes a lot of sense why is she
having so much momentum that's a great
question number one she's being helped
out by these social media companies i
would love to see how act how many of
her actual followers are real let's just
put that out there because they are
being heavily promoted more than
conservative voices which is why we need
counter voices to them
but i think look she was she's relatable
she does these you know little videos
she was one of the first millennials
that had a strong voice in congress
everybody knew about her she was put on
this pedestal and she was heavily
marketed by the powers that be in her
party people believed in her and even if
she disrupted her establishment
candidate she was still heavily backed
and funded by people who propped her up
and so she's able to penetrate in all
these different areas whether it's
twitch or social media and all that to
try to be relatable now everything that
she says ninety percent of it does not
make sense but we live especially
millennials live in this kind of
soundbite culture where they take this
emotion based little 15 second things
that she says and then they go and run
with it as we see with these culture
wars and then that's why she's so
effective but she's actually destroying
her party at the the advantage to
conservatives because people are now
coming more on our side because she's
controlling the democrats today she
controls the narrative because she's
able to raise money on her own because
of her big platform and she has the
voice to do it do you think she's dumb
yes you think she's that i do really i
think she's dumb uh no okay i'll say
this she's smart because she's smart at
manipulating i think is anybody like
that
is deceptive okay in terms of raw
intelligence um i would say some of her
things that she says about the economy
and things just don't make sense so from
that perspective no so economically and
her degree is in what isn't her degree
in economics yeah isn't it isn't it
economics so yeah some of the stuff she
talks about
it just makes you wonder like who
who the teachers are today i'd love to
go to college i'd love to go to one of
these uc berkeley economic classes just
to sit there as a student just to sit
there and be like go semester through
like a project you know what i'm saying
like you recorded and you wonder what
these professors are telling these kids
that are going to college about economy
what are they saying about the rich man
about the capitalists about the business
owner uh what kind of commentary because
they're shaping the mindset of these
kids so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]
you